i've got it the previous leons will stop
once marvel's wasted a collective five
years of my life giving me a greater
appreciation for those who lived through
the blip oh [ __ ] that takes us up to the
year 2364.
why do tv shows think that showing a
character hearing a suspicious noise but
choosing to dismiss it is any less
ridiculous than the character just not
hearing said noise so he gets to turn
his cane into an axe staff just for
finding amit's game piece show us some
weird level ups lelax like this is some
kind of burial at sea and that she
doesn't just submerge him in this gummy
surface runoff that's found its way into
this ancient egyptian tomb also layla's
seen some pretty crazy [ __ ] at this
point so wouldn't she at least think
about preserving mark's body knowing the
shenanigans konchu might be able to pull
to revive him it's pretty stupid to
leave behind the one thing that could
potentially lead someone back to the
shopti in arthur's possession it's an
entire distinct pantheon of stupidity
unto itself to leave said thing with
someone who has already been returned
from the brink of death once before
while said person's companion is still
at large of course the above is made
totally moved because layla doesn't even
use the damn thing to track harrow she
just follows them out of the damn tomb
and gets into the car with them how do
checkpoints even work on this road
people seem to be traversing this
territory in every which way they please
come to think of it why did they
approach the checkpoint at all instead
of just continuing on through this
well-traveled desert you need to show us
your soul the righteous ray of reckoning
was omnidirectional so why didn't it
cast its periwinkle wave over layla
purple purple purple purple staff brown
suit judging all the people rolled up at
the checkpoint judging judging all the
people people falling around the people
stealing purple from the people people
falling around the people cuz my evil
purple steeple people this is the face
of a good man said without seeing his
face you don't need this anymore hey
that's my line don't do it
leila wait i am the goddess to wet it
yeah never mind that's not weird at all
and no way worthy of anything more than
a slight sideways glance onwards well i
was standing right there in the middle
of these [ __ ] and no one even
notices there may be good people
according to ahmed but i'm wondering if
a more strict criteria should be
followed in terms of recruitment maybe
more of a focus on situational awareness
does this staff come with a [ __ ]
instruction manual how does hero know
this will open up the pyramid why
harrow that's your who not your why this
doesn't need to happen yes please
immediately cut away from the epic
battle of the gods i'm sure this
showdown will hold absolutely zero
interest for any of us you rotten [ __ ]
teases this is all so avoidable indeed
all the confusing character motivations
were avoidable and i'm happy you've come
around to my point of view all the
avatars die and since the only one we
hear from is towerette we must assume
that the rest of the gods were like oh
well you win some you lose some really
undercuts how important any of this is
and makes you wonder why almond and
conscious are so invested so to trump
the scouts in these statues it takes a
ceremony with five avatars casting a
spell while holding hands but to release
them from the statue you just spike it
on the ground in the end zone well so
i'm pretty sure we're supposed to infer
that the ushabti has to be smashed
inside this specific end zone in order
to free the kinder surprise inside if
not why wouldn't hero have destroyed it
as soon as he got his hands on it and if
so why aren't these pesky gods
imprisoned in the uchoptia and then
yielded outside so there's zero chance
of exactly the situation ever happening
why keep them in the one place they can
be freed by a passing breeze your scales
lack balance kind of a big thing to say
to the person that just freed you
imagine if the first thing your boss
said to you when they got back from
vacation was you suck and you're a bad
person they lack balance because of what
lies ahead of you what lies ahead of you
is your service to me now imagine if
your boss said you suck and you're a bad
person because you work for me also this
might be a weird question but i'm
beginning to wonder if anyone bothered
to check if the scales have been
properly calibrated because you won't
win against harrow and amit alone
i'll take my chances i understand not
wanting to work with khan shu but the
alternative is taking your chances
fighting a god all alone with only your
unfounded optimism at your side
time has been cruel to you i'd say he's
a [ __ ] skeleton but the writer should
know that when i point these things out
you get one sin and when you point them
out but don't provide an explanation you
get three sins now my call i'm only a
humble avatar for cindy the goddess of
snark and protector of the tv syntheon
leave here and you can't return show
thinks this is an ultimate sacrifice but
they've been breaking more rules in the
afterlife than bill and ted so i'm
pretty sure mark just figures there's
probably a workaround so i get to go on
to eternal peace before you get too
excited about eternal peace think
carefully about wandering around this
wheat forever
you saved me
blip
i'm throwing this down
yeah but why did your leg fall asleep
you were frozen for way less time than
steven so i don't think you should be
taking this long to thaw because this is
marvel of course no one's powers are
explained or quantified but i think it's
safe to say these two gods should have
more in their arsenal to try before
having to resort to bashing into one
another i choose obliteration over mercy
other than ghosting yourself out of this
place which is exactly what he does when
he realizes mark is back was that not
always an option i kind of remember
removing sins for marvel being brave
enough to kill off a main character and
then something about promising to resend
them if they didn't follow through i
apologize if all that feels a bit
inconsistent but if the show is going to
be vague with what is and isn't reality
i'm going to be vague with what is and
isn't cynical
how's this deal going to work
you would negotiate no
we're so much at stake kanchu would be
amun raw at tv sins
i will release you both you'll have my
word i'm sure the show would never rely
on subtle distinctions in language to
allow khanshu to keep his word and for
the moon knighting to continue sure that
would never happen now how the heck are
we going to get to cairo you forget
little world
i am still the blonde of the night sky
yes but how does that work in the middle
of the day he's either accelerating the
rotation of the earth to make it night
prematurely or he's accelerating the
passage of time itself he either would
seem to be get some unintended side
effects
we need to imprison on it
in a mortal form nobody instead of a
statue if a person is being used as a
vessel similar to a statue how does this
make amit more vulnerable to get out
ahmet should just have to break the
person like they broke the statue maybe
not just like the statue it'd be pretty
hard to spike a person into the ground
with that much force we need more
avatars
than we have
my dm to james cameron somehow makes its
way into this episode ahmet starts
sucking up all these souls and grows
super tall which i thought was weird on
its own but then konchu does the same
thing after eating zero souls so now we
have no idea if the soul munching was
necessary or all for show i'm gonna go
with yes i'm sending the needlessly
aggressive deployment of this wing sword
combination as a potential hazard and
public nuisance
falcon in the lunar soldier
this is a great moment for
representation so i'm taking a sin off
for the kid out there that feels in this
moment included in the cultural
phenomenon that is the superhero genre
but this kid also stayed in harm's way
to ask this question and that's not the
type of curiosity we want to encourage
this is the equivalent of trapping a few
feathers it's not even the meat of the
wing i mean her arm basically scarlet
scarab can't wriggle out of this one
because plot the fight between kanchu
and ahmet seems mostly inconsequential
the literal god fight takes a backseat
to the avatars and while it's nice to
see that marvel is more aware of the
inherent problems here than dc the story
seems to be trying to ignore it
okay buddy make sure you really test the
bulletproof nature of that wing before
trying your legs hands or any other
exposed body parts yeah show subverts
the whole how's he gonna get out of this
one by not showing it at all and asking
us to just assume that whatever happened
was cool for the millionth time what the
hell was that the viewer's reaction to
this scene somehow makes its way into
the episode muhammad is dragging away
what looks like an unconscious consu
unconscious shoe but how does that even
happen can gods be knocked unconscious i
suppose this could all just be a
metaphysical battle being presented to
human eyes in a way that can be easily
comprehended but why
that haro i know how to stop ahmed i
probably wouldn't bother layla judging
by the way harrow's neck stays perfectly
straight as mark lifts him i'm fairly
certain rigor mortis is already set in
yeah i don't
don't think you know as much as you
think you do who me oh no i know exactly
what's going on i have a firm grasp on
what's real and what's actually just in
mark steven or mystery player number
three's head i mean i could totally
explain it to you but it took far too
long really and i wouldn't want to bore
you here's what we'll do when when you
figure it out come back and tell me and
willem compare notes you know just so
that i know that you know and will be
avoiding spoiling anything you didn't
realize you didn't know you know we'd
rather go save the world saying this
after you've decided to no longer be the
moon night is like taking your
glass-filled shoes off after you've
already suffered massive blood loss
meet my friend
jake lockley
show does not end with a moon knight
will return leaving me with so many
unanswered questions why are mark and
steven unaware of oscar the grouch is he
another coping mechanism created by mark
if so why is he speaking italian why did
the egyptian gods intervene with ahmet's
plans but not thanos and when will we
see the glorious hippo lady again
serving ahmed is tough business long
nights strange hours and even stranger
places if you told me one day i'd be
snatching souls straight out of people's
bodies i'd have had a good chuckle but
that's the thing about life sometimes it
takes you down the road less traveled
and sometimes it takes you off the road
completely and when i go off-road i
always depend on my ford raptor built to
survive the wrath of the gods built for
tough
they do not see what lies ahead when sun
has failed the moon is dead
phenomenal cosmic powers
itty-bitty
these aren't the droids you're looking
for
not
pass
open sesame
you don't need him anymore mark i need
my right hand man back
[Music]
new teeth that's weird so where was i
[Music]
oh no mother hush bucket
[Applause]
let's show this prehistoric [ __ ] how we
do things downtown
i'm really jazzed about showing you
these new skill sets we have
show me what you got